ab wann ist man eigentlich
computerspielabhängig die
weltgesundheitsorganisation wto hat
dieses jahr im entwurf der elfter
revision des ice idee der international
statistical classification of diseases
das ist quasi das weltweite verzeichnis
von krankheiten exzessives gaming als
psychische störung eingeführt jetzt ist
es also amtlich und dass er ist quasi
die amtliche bekanntmachung jetzt gibt
es keine ausreden mehr bei klick zum
science fiction hier gibt's täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal nur dann verpasst er nichts
herzlich willkommen eine computerspiel
abhängigkeit wird im eis cd der
international statistik classification
of diseases als gaming disorder
bezeichnet und ist unter dem schüssel 6c
51 aufgeführt womit sie im bereich der
mentalen verhaltens und neuro
entwicklungsstörungen eingeordnet ist
allerdings streiten fachleute über die
berechtigung des exzessiven gamings als
eigenständiges störungsbild eigentlich
gesunde kinder und jugendliche laufen
gefahr zu unrecht stigmatisiert und
diagnostiziert zu werden
die entwicklung von videospielen der
letzten jahre zeigt das zocken
mittlerweile wohl im alltag etabliert
und normal ist digitale spiele sind in
bestimmten lebensphasen von besonderer
bedeutung wie auch andere
freizeitaktivitäten auch und da ist das
spielen von videospielen selbst wenn es
häufiger vorkommen sollte nicht gänzlich
ungewöhnlich wenn sich allerdings
fachleute dieser medienrealität
versperren laufen sie gefahr die gaming
sucht viel zu diagnostizieren und dabei
andere störungen wie depressionen zu
übersehen also ab wann gilt man nach
fachmeinung als computerspielsüchtig und
was passiert mit einem videospiel so
wird durch ein tief greifendes muster
anhaltenden und wiederholten spielen von
computerspielen
da fasse ich jetzt mal alle
elektronischen oder software gesteuerten
spiele zusammen charakterisiert das kann
online und offline seien die symptome
eingeschränkte kontrolle über das
spielen zb beginn häufigkeit intensität
dauer beenden zunehmende priorität für
das spielen in dem maße dass es
wichtiger wird als andere interessen im
leben wie freundschaften zb und
alltägliche aktivitäten
fortsetzung oder steigerung des spielens
trotz auftretens negativer konsequenzen
für die diagnose einer gaming sucht muss
das verhaltensmuster ausreichend stark
sein dazu gehören beispielsweise
erhebliche beeinträchtigungen der
persönlichen familiären sozialen
schulischen oder beruflichen
funktionsbereiche die mindestens zwölf
monate lang offensichtlich sind so jetzt
habt ihr das und wenn erfahren wollt wie
das bei ford als süchtig macht dann
schaut euch das video von geronimo
anmacht vormals süchtig eine gaming
psychologische analyse um den hype hier
geht es zum abo von geronimo und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt daran darauf
klicken draufklicken draufklicken profi